determina si 394 es mayor que o menor
que 397 escribe la expresión usando este
símbolo o este símbolo y este símbolo es
el de menor que más adelante veremos
cómo recordar cuál símbolo es cuál menor
que y este es el mayor qué
lo primero que vamos a hacer es analizar
los números 394 y 397 escribimos 394 y
el otro número es 397 ambos tienen 300
así que el lugar de las centenas es
equivalente
ambos tienen 90 estos nueves acá pero
este es 300 más 90 más 4 y este de aquí
es 300 más 90 más 7 y nosotros sabemos
que 4 es menor que 7 si vemos la recta
numérica el 4 aparece antes que el 7 si
llegamos contando al 7 habremos contado
el 4
así que 394 es menor que 397 la forma en
la que escribimos esto es
394 es menor que 397 y la forma en la
que yo me acuerdo que esto significa
menor que menor que
es que el número más pequeño está del
lado de la parte del símbolo que es más
pequeña pueden ver que este lado es
mucho más pequeño que este otro lado y
también lo podemos escribir de la otra
forma
397 es mayor que 394 y nuevamente el
número más grande va a estar del lado de
la parte más grande del símbolo la parte
hacia la cual se abre este símbolo en
este punto es la parte más pequeña esto
de aquí es la parte más grande que
siempre va a estar del lado del número
más grande